the raiders playing the atlanta falcons
for the first time since back in 2016
sports director chris matthews joining
us live in studio with more on the key
to stopping the falcons four-game
winning streak over las vegas
thank you brian the last time the
raiders beat the falcons was in 2000 the
key to snapping that skid
will be the play of quarterback derek
carr when they last played in atlanta he
was having an mvp type season that was
in 2016.
here we are in 2020 and again he's
having an mvp type season
but carr is quick to point out it's not
just him
the more dynamic the surrounding cast
the better play from the quarterback
it does help when you get to be in the
same system for three years it does help
when you're hearing the same voice in
the headset you're hearing the same
voice
you know monday through saturday you
know here it helps to have
continuity up front and at skill
positions
and quarterback is a great position that
we all love to talk about but i i
cannot do it alone and no one no one in
this world can
no matter how how awesome we think
certain guys are and things like that
if you change the situation for them
things will be different
well the game at mercedes-benz stadium
will have some fancy you know there will
be members of raider nation there it's
at 10 a.m kickoff pacific time
here on your network home for the
raiders cbs